hello everybody my name is markiplier
and we are back where it all began if
anybody remembers little piggy no no
started right here when he threw me out
that window and I went down there in
order to not be able to go out the front
doors and wait be my unlock those front
doors aren't they open now can't I go
down there probably probably not I have
no idea but who knows maybe I will be
able to go down there yes alright that
guy seemed kind of not normal but
whatever so I need to find the key
behind the light in the theater no it
couldn't be this easy yeah I could I can
squeeze through the hit that gap right
there I could definitely if I was in a
survival situation that would be through
that gap in out here in no time
I would freaking fall through that
window again just to be able to get out
of here okay so I need to get the key
and the theater behind the lie because
the father is a son of a [ __ ] who likes
to put me through a lot of tests that I
don't need to be through more dead
bodies different music almost soothing
music what's going on now
what awaits me in the theatre does
anybody remember the moment from the
first Bioshock if you haven't played it
yet you're gonna like the part with the
theater you know does anyone know what
I'm talking about
that's what I was reminded of when I
said yet
the fit okay all right so we need to go
watch a movie and then we'll be on our
merry way in order to be able to do
whatever the hell we want to do anything
in the corner that is awfully nice but
somber music who plays I wonder who
plays maybe whatever this morphogenetic
engine does turned all the female
patients into male patients ergo there
are no women in here what a sad sad
existence to be turned into a disgusting
man Oh oh no keep playing I really liked
what you oh boy hi there
hi friend yeah you're one of those
weirdos with no mouths but you were
doing good all right whatever
surprise your pianos still in tune ha ha
fellow piano players know what I'm
saying I leave it for a day to get out
of whatever shut up ok go through here
and it ah the theatre the theatre behind
the line wait give me through there we
go okay so I need to watch a movie next
to this guy
exit interview recorded to December 27th
1985 in Los Alamos New Mexico okay I
should probably record this doctor now
not 4 9 6 6
there was no alteration to the footage
at all no trickery huh
in June of 1943 you recorded 3 instances
of spontaneous bleeding uh-huh
a half a dozen test subjects began to
develop brain tumors that's not good yes
that you must swear pure dead what it
killed them can you explain why the
results could not be reproduced in the
United States I have my theories my
homeland in those years it's impossible
to understand the things we've helped
what does that even mean you need German
words to be expressing that rage if you
say something ha C Mo's record acted
what did I write down hang on one second
the man sounds like dr. Strangelove's
anemic brother its 20th that's very
clever reference right there it's a 25
year old audio recording an interview
with its dr. Wernicke los alamos means
government work wernicke talks about
spontaneous bleeding tumors
psychosomatic reactions insufficiently
disturbed people seems to walk a line
between science and nazi mysticism only
a test subject could witnessed enough
horror was capable of activating the
engine the morphogenetic engine whatever
hell that is the engine the movie
they're protecting it gets in my head
like a song you can't stop humming I
blink and see a Rorschach test that
looked like swarming insects and
infected surgery wounds the patients
talk about using the engine to conjure
the walrider
it's the buzzing I hear in my bones you
know now that they mention it this guy
watching this has been through quite a
lot probably able to activate the world
morphogenetic engine don't be doing that
gateway to hell gateway to hell it's
probably what they're trying to say it's
a gateway to hell or something like that
alright so I need to find the key behind
the light I'm assuming it's up in the
projection room hello take this off for
a second slam that shut open this up and
it's dark as balls okay someone in there
oh okay fine how you doing otherwise
you're doing good all right I'm
activating the morphogenetic engine okay
whatever need to did he say need to find
wernicki wait that didn't register for a
second there Dadu whatever god what
really necrotizing fasciitis really off
whooping quit really over that that's
what causes you to quit you see all
these Horrors beyond horror oh wait no
this all happened recently so I don't
think it's like that okay crawl under go
into the projection room trying to find
a key so I can go upstairs
and punch the priest in his face punch
him right in his face
hello hi hi there can you let me in how
about you let me in please I won't hurt
you
maybe I am turning into the monster here
maybe that's all why they all want to
stop me they know what I'm capable of so
uh what do I do about that what do I do
about that
battery um I probably shouldn't grab
that without replacing it first because
I am now full up on stuff hey this door
mysteriously opened how strange
okay another legs I can barely crawl
across I like this this is my favorite
game okay hopefully when I grab onto
that ledge over there the guy won't grab
my arms and throw me off was it
something that people want to do in
these situations so I have something
stuck in my throat
and leap epic jump I made it now where's
this a-hole that stopped me before
oh come on he opened the door and left
cuz he's a big baby fine whatever screw
you and your face leap oh so pro no drop
down how do I drop down drop yeah there
we go
like a mouse epic parkour what No
new it's probably the naked twins isn't
it definitely the naked twins definately
the naked twins I hear some hard to tell
with all the dead bodies anybody
I don't see anyone where are they where
the heck are they I hear footsteps you
can't tell me I don't but I don't see it
oh there oh there you are hot as you I
knew it
you're so naked gonna stick you right
past you
oh you're so stupid where's your brother
to help you out you're obviously the
dumb one I don't even need to crawl it's
so stupid man so stupid I shouldn't make
fun of them so much well hi there you're
naked you're Nikki like the day you were
born
okay so anyway oh I gotta get through to
there so if you could do as well I'm
gonna get the [ __ ] out of the way be
awfully nice alright what am I gonna do
about chasing through here maybe I'll
just give him the runaround Hey
hi you [ __ ] alright your brother's
smarter than you what are you doing
you're just standing there really say
what now
maybe I was supposed to talk to him
maybe mine yeah yeah yeah this is carry
on may have been a bug or something he
wasn't posing
come on man I just got up here I just
got up here
this is how it's gonna be this is my
life is the story of my life
bunch of a-holes trying to impede my
progress non-stop over and over again
Oh is there a go summon the wall rider
the wall right is that him is that mr.
priest II that's not mr. priest II is it
hi hi hey hey I want a word with you
you're not the priests never mind you're
you got no pants on never mind how about
over there behind door number one no
okay I just want to meet this priest not
to punch him in the face
no of course not but yeah to punch him
in the face
what are you doing
what are you doing the static again a
patient knelt in prayer maybe he bought
father Martin's line of [ __ ] maybe
here's what he what I hear but more
clearly maybe it's his way out of this
place the priest called it the gospel of
sand is there something in the shadows
wait a minute
no I can kind of see something wait am I
going crazy or do I actually see
something in the static here like a
little little dude do you guys see that
it's like a little pattern around my
reticle moving around or I'm going crazy
I don't know but I'm pretty sure I see
something in there yeah right there
right there I see a face or something
not enough I see oh it's even better now
here wait you can definitely see it you
can definitely see it it's there
I don't know if it'll come out through
video but I can definitely see it's a
pair of eyes its eyes maybe it's getting
more clear because I'm looking at it
longer I can see it okay anyway
was that getting louder okay whatever
all right whatever no time for that we
got to get going I am going psycho
bonkers crazy
okay little piggy no no little piggy go
home hey sorry to bother you're doing
your prayer really I had to go all this
way around when I couldn't nevermind
hello somebody on the toilet someone
having some trouble someone needs some
help to wipe okay hello how's it going
there you're doing good need a glass of
water some milk need help going to sleep
need someone to sing you warm kitty soft
kitty oh he's got a bottle of soda right
there well good good knows that he's
getting his soda pop okay I'm assuming
this is just gonna be a bunch of dorms
full of these guys praying somehow they
escape the other guy's completely insane
can I go out there tonight leap out that
window and fall to my death I kind of
would like that just a little bit
seriously be just a bunch of a whole
bunch of people praying I'm gonna go out
that window just to see what's out there
today oh hello
I can go out here too there does that
help me in any way let's try it it seems
like a dumb idea but I'm hoping it'll
lead me to something an easter egg maybe
well maybe this is just the way I'm
supposed to go I have no idea
hello okay whose product is away of
course ago
God hates sickness really does he now
God hates money yeah it probably does
you see God hey a noise who always
provides away hey buddy can you give me
away can you get out of my way I'll go
I'll make my camera go crazy on you okay
whatever oh this way okay I see
hi it's a naked twins okay
the promise of the prophets was always
freedom from death right and together we
will be free
[Music]
now what
oh damn for me to be going on my way you
have fun with your fire party there I'm
gonna go out this way say goodbye to the
naked twins bye thanks for all the fish
okay
I can't believe father Martin won up
Jesus Christ himself in shitty ways to
die and I don't believe I'm gonna miss
him a way out if he's telling the truth
now I've got a way out at this story to
tell he wants me to spread his gospel
I'll tell the whole [ __ ] world
oh this guy is a this why he's a
journalist cuz he's a clever writer now
how do I get out there wait which way I
go the way that that guy was blocking me
before that's right okay
is he still uh yeah he's a gone you guys
are still naked so uh fun with that have
fun with all your crazy psycho bonkers
miss I'm gonna go away forever away
forever my goodness huh okay let's see
what we got going on oh no it's a big
guy it's a big guy where'd he come from
let's see if I can lead him on a wild
goose chase yeah oh I see this was this
was a dead end so I just gotta lead him
in a circle in here oh I see what you're
doing
[ __ ] you stop stupid oh you're so stupid
oh you're so stupid
come on man come on oh you're uh you're
kind of close there Oh No I've gone the
wrong way what the hell am I supposed to
do oh wait no I've gone the right way
okay yes I am okay oh I see I see I see
okay gimme gimme yeah okay now I guess I
gotta keep going because he's gonna be
coming after me okay and then we go down
or to the elevator yes yes yes I'm gonna
get out of here or not I'm ready for
that outcome too
well this was a long way to go for what
no you bastard you bastard
no god damn it I knew it couldn't be
that easy I knew it couldn't I knew it
couldn't be that easy I find another way
out [ __ ] you I bet I can't I bet I don't
get to find a what I bet I don't get to
find another way out I bet I bet this is
yen cuz the wall riders gonna come up
poke me in the butt and then gonna be
gone and done him dead there's that
symbol again oh this is the thing this
is where those soldiers got killed this
must be the containment area for the
walrider project yeah indeed it is wow
that guy got killed spectacularly
alright then let's read up now shall we
Frankenstein or the modern prometheus by
Mary Shelley published anonymously in
1818 chapter 23 exit man I cried how he
grew [ __ ] Valens I pride of wisdom
cease you know not what it is you say I
broke from the house angry and disturbed
I'm retired to meditate on some other
mode of action oh all right
it looks like the epic conclusion is
upon us I will finish this all in one
part I just don't want this to be like
the end of mad father and it carries on
for an hour so anyway thank you all so
much for watching get ready for the
ending of this series in the next part
maybe I dunno so thanks again and as
always I will see
in the next video
man that was fast
really really
[ __ ] yourself that shots aren't gonna
working out there guys
[Music]
you're coming off Jesus Christ come on
before I cut up its [ __ ] leg this
bull think I do not want to die okay I